foreign
[Music]
was still available on Netflix Daredevil
was one of the most popular spin-offs of
the Defenders after the contract between
Netflix and Marvel was not renewed a few
years ago the rights moved back to the
MCU and thus the popular character could
already celebrate its return in 2021 in
Spider-Man no way home with a brief
appearance in today's original we talk
about the first solo project in the MCU
and tell you everything you need to know
about the 2024 Disney plus series
Daredevil born again have fun with our
new video
before thinking about the plot one
important question should be answered
first is Daredevil Born Again a reboot a
standalone series or even a continuation
of the events from the Netflix series
lead actor Charlie Cox already provided
the answer in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly towards the end of
last year according to Cox the
differences between his MCU role and his
Netflix role are part of Matt Murdoch's
natural development still in essence
they're one in the same character Cox
also addressed the fact that the Netflix
series was rather gloomy as the main
character's life was simply under a lot
of pressure at the time and the mood was
thus adapted to what was happening when
Cox's character made his first
appearances in Spider-Man no way home
and She-Hulk the mood was clearly
different and more lighthearted so that
Murdoch also finds his place in this
world without being a totally different
character nevertheless it is considered
almost certain that the series will be a
reboot of the Netflix series according
to Cox some aspects of the story will be
retold but other circumstances may be
Rewritten various favorite moments from
the three seasons on Netflix will be
shown again in a different set it
remains exciting to see how well the MCU
approach will be received by the
audience
apart from the main character Matt
Murdock who will again be played by
Charlie Cox many fans are asking
themselves about other actors returning
or suitable newcomers one of the first
confirmed comebacks is Vincent D'Onofrio
as Kingpin who could already be seen in
the Hawkeye series released in 2021
likewise joining the cast is Netflix
actress I let zurer as Vanessa Fisk
kingpin's wife Michael Gandolfini the
son of soprano star James Gandolfini is
also set to take on an unknown role his
experience apart from The Sopranos
prequel the many Saints of Newark has so
far been limited to supporting roles and
rather unfamiliar films Daredevil born
again could therefore mean the big step
into Hollywood for the 24 year old just
earlier this year the signing of House
of the Dragon actor Artie frusian was
also revealed who is to play an
important character named Harry the
absolute past standout alongside Charlie
Cox and dinofrio however is someone else
namely John Bernthal who once again
Graces us with his role as Frank Castle
AKA The Punisher in this case fans will
be primarily wondering to what extent
character retains its resemblance to the
Netflix series since the Punisher is
definitely one of the more violent
Defenders
the Disney plus series is written by
Covert Affairs authors Matt Corman and
Chris ort who are both working on an MCU
project for the first time they will be
supported by Naomi writer Jill
Blankenship and the Flash author green
Godfrey both of whom have already gained
experience at least at Marvel's
competitor DC Dexter director Michael
Cuesta will direct the pilot episode The
Day After Tomorrow writer Jeffrey
nakpanoff will also be in charge of
directing other directors have not been
revealed yet the series is to comprise a
total of 18 episodes and will thus be
quite extensive this is also reflected
in the duration of filming which started
in March in New York and the surrounding
area originally filming was scheduled to
take eight months but due to the ongoing
writer strike the production will be
delayed it is currently impossible to
say whether the completion of filming in
November 2023 can be met provided there
are no major delays it will then be
possible to watch the First episodes of
Daredevil Born Again In Spring 2024 on
Disney Plus
what are your wishes for the upcoming
Daredevil series do you want a series
that's as close to the Netflix one as
possible or do you want something more
similar to the MCU feel free to let us
know in the comments
[Music]
thank you